you can't convince a group of
chimpanzees to come together to fight a
war or build a cathedral by promising to
them if you do that after you die you go
to chimpanzee heaven and you get lots of
bananas and coconuts no chimpanzee will
ever believe that humans believe these
stories which is why we have these huge
religious networks but it's the same
thing with modern politics it's the same
thing with economics people think oh
economics this is rational it has
nothing to do with fictional stories no
money is the most successful Story Ever
Told much more successful than any
religious mythology not everybody
believes in God or in the same God every
but almost everybody believes in money
even though it's just a figment of our
imagination
you know you take these green pieces of
paper dollars they have no value you
can't eat them you can't drink them and
today most dollars are not even pieces
of paper they are just electronic
information passing between computers
we value them
just for one reason that you have the
best storytellers in the world
the bankers the finance ministers all
these people they are the best
storytellers ever
and they tell us a story that this green
little piece of paper or this bit of
information it is worth a banana and as
long as everybody believes it it works
so at which point does a fiction when
it's sufficiently useful and effective
and improving the global quality of life
does it become
like accept the reality like there's a
threshold which is just you know people
believe it it's like with money you know
if you start a new cryptocurrency if if
you're the only one that believes the
story again you you cryptocurrencies you
have the math of course but ultimately
it's storytelling you're selling people
a story if nobody believes your story
you don't have anything but if lots of
people believe the Bitcoin story then
Bitcoin can be worth thousands and tens
of thousands of dollars again why I mean
you can't eat it you can't drink it it's
nothing it's the story around the the
math which is the real magic